mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compaq 10 vous présente double jeu
l'émission de thierry ardisson
je
m
[Musique]
fini pour moi
m
[Musique]
et
ce soit en programme double jeu retrouvé
le golf de la semaine et les clapton
aïcha de chérif qu'elle quitte le
document de la semaine les platters
bruit depuis tanner les couples se
forment jean leloup le genre de singles
et avec lesquels au québec
roch voisine martika oui chérie on en
pince pour l'égérie de prince plus les
infos intox de philippe guérin les
bonnes lourdes laurent baffie les
platines nord de philippe corti et en
invité le dette énorme et villa
je vous écoute je sais pas quelque chose
qui va pas mais je sais pas quoi
votre enfance comment était-elle
structurés je me souviens qu'une fois il
y avait une course de ski dans le dans
le petit village où j'habite et j'avais
pas fais la course mais mais j'avais
fait la une du dauphiné libéré
mais cette enfance particulière de qui
il était entouré je sais pas je recevais
des coûts élevés des mêmes gens qui
avaient sur l'écran de la télé qui par
exemple levé nana mouskouri
vous fêtez le penser à une fille que je
voulais l'épouser camp quand j'avais 20
ans l'avait démis les mêmes lunettes
horrible on est encore et mireille
mathieu mais elle je savais qu'elle se
marierait jeunes n'y avait-il pas un
homme une sorte de frère putatif qui
vous aurez beaucoup influençant n'ont
pas pu te tue
mais on a dit qu'on en parle de passe
soit il précisé quel prix
cette année je ne crois pas que j'y
retournerai
[Musique]
et
ça te fait quoi de rencontre et en
double parfois très mauvais effet et toi
le matin quand tu es devant la glace
comment tu poses j'évite de me regarder
dans la glace le matin mais alors
vraiment
pas t'aurais aimé ressembler à qui quand
tu étais petit alain delon tiens tiens
pourquoi pas à moi quand j'étais petit
j'étais pas terrible avant tu changerais
quoi si tu avais une baguette magique en
toi ma hauteur je trouve que c'est un
peu court sur pattes
qu'est ce que tu as de plus sexy en toi
donc à bout intéressant est ce que tu
m'as borderais si tu me rencontrer non
tu m'aimes pas tous les jours quelle est
l'insulté qui t'a fait le plus mal
[ __ ]
quand as-tu pleurer pour la dernière
fois avant-hier tu es content de ta vie
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est un débat dans
lequel je ne veux pas rentrer ce soir
qu'est ce que tu écris lorsqu'on te
demande un autographe si c'est une femme
j'écris tendresse si c'est un garçon
j'écris amitié hervé vilard
bonsoir bonsoir alors tu es né un 24
juillet est ce qu'on peut dire l'année
as tu dis ton âge je suis né à paris
dans un taxi le 24 ans vont parler 1946
lyon ascendant lion cette séquelle âge
attend alors ça je ne sais plus quel
joueur 46 ans a dit pas mal quel est le
secret de ton éternel look d'adolescent
je crois que je me suis bien accroché je
m'éclate bien tous les jours
j'aime beaucoup la vie j'ai quand même
des amis qui me donne la pêche oui t'as
pas fait de lifter grains non message
non mais je pourrais pas le dire ce soir
à chelles tu comprends même si j'en fais
si j'ai des secrets de pharmaciens de
chirurgien peut pas le dévoiler ça c'est
pas possible
alors justement tu es né dans un taxi à
5 heures du matin dans le taxi qui
amenait tamer l'hôpital saint-antoine
c'est ça ça c'est vrai ça c'est autant
ce n'est pas la légende ça l'info ça
fait de l'intox
ah oui et d'ailleurs quand tu as
retrouvé la trace de ton père on va en
parler plus tard il était aperçu qu'il
était aussi chauffeur de taxi oui mais
j'ai d'abord joué au texte j'ai d'abord
retrouver ma mère m'en vais en parler
alors tu dis toujours que dans les
articles des interviews il toujours que
ta mère était marchand de viol est en
fait était concierge mais je trouve ça
plus poétique de dire dans ma mère était
a été aussi fleuriste c'est à dire qu'à
l'époque il y avait une
on a vu dans les films de carnets tous
ses films sur les faubourgs et tout ça
ça existait vraiment il y avait ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui bon qu'elle me
pardonne des groupies et ma mère était
une admiratrice de maurice chevalier de
fréhel de piaf et faisait un peu partie
de la bande comme
je peux avoir aujourd'hui des
admirateurs qu'on appelle des femmes ma
mère faisait partie de ces gens-là et
a vécu en vendant des violettes et les
partitions c'est pas la légion ne fait
pas rire les gens mais non non non non
et pourquoi tête ont retiré à elle par
décision judiciaire
c'est une
c'est un peu dur de le dire mais ma mère
avait des accents comme ça elle aimait
beaucoup le bordeaux c'était grave soit
disant pour ses voisins
alors elle a été dénoncée on marque on
m'a retiré on enlevait et j'ai été
confiée à la dass est-ce qu'on a su qui
l'a dénoncé non jamais non mais si je
tiens le [ __ ] je peux te garantir que
même aujourd'hui lorsque ma mère a
culpabilisé jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
pour toi tu as été mis à la dass tu as
été mis à l'hospice saint vincent de
paul
c'est j'étais placé à l'assistance
publique définitivement âge de 6 ans et
c'était quoi la vie là-bas j'étais un
enfant assez chouchouter parce que ma
mère n'ayant pas le droit de venir me
voir comme d'autres pouvaient venir voir
leurs enfants
j'avais pas le droit de visite quoi
alors j'étais un chouchouté par les
infirmières a les bonnes soeurs de
l'epap et tu as dit en parlant de cette
époque je suis persuadé qu'on faisait
sur nous des expériences médicales
mais j'ai un jeu reste je suis perçu par
d'une chose qui s'appelle la punition
piqûre
ouais mais ça veut dire que c'était
comme un argentine dans ce centre qu'on
a trouvés ou où on utilisait les enfants
pour des expériences médicales ou et je
voudrais pas faire de la délation comme
ça ce soir
on parle de cinq ans vous parle d'autre
chose mais je pense qu'on a testé ce
puisque nous appartenions à l'assistance
publique et l'assistance publique c'est
bien c'est bien les hôpitaux de paris de
la france et donc on a je reste
intimement persuadé qu'on a fait des
expériences des expériences à l'époque
mais elle doit peut-être bonne puisque
nous voilà en pleine forme
tu penseras tester des médicaments sur
vous les médicaments dans tous les cas
c'était pablo ou enfin des bcg j'en ai
eu quand même quelques-uns comme moi
apparemment effectivement mouais c'est
peut-être ça et ça qu'ils gardent encore
et à l'époque [ __ ] vente un papa
fictif jean vilar ouais il n'y avait pas
d'aimer c'est pas grave tu mettais des
photos de lui ces faits touchant ça tu
mettais des photos de lui dans ta dans
ta chambre tu expliquer à ses petits
camarades de l'époque que c'était en
tête on perd en fait c'est vrai c'est
vrai j'ai toujours une grande admiration
et encore aujourd'hui pour les actes et
il y avait jean vilar parce qu'il
portait le même nom que moi alors je
disais oh bah mon père il n'a pas le
temps enfin je m'inventais des monde
aime ça et d'aider c'est vrai que
j'étais assez à ces menteurs ses beats
hausse énorme assez miteux oui alors tu
as été mis donc effectivement dans des
fermes puisque un moment le président
cottier avait décidé que les petits de
la dass serez mis dans des fermes où es
tu te retrouve chez un dénommé nénesse à
un moment mais et tu te conduis assez
bien lui aussi ça se passe assez bien et
puis un jour tu avais des sabots tavel
et avait pas de souliers
c'est authentique tout ça et tu as quand
même piquer un peu de blé comme ça pour
acheter des vrais souliers c'est exact
et à virey c'est pas lui qui
viré tu vois je sais pas tout tu veux
mais tu sais beaucoup de choses parce
que c'est tout tout est là c'est que je
crois que mon destin est lié à ce petit
détail
enfin mon destin de chanteurs ma vie
d'artiste
et il est vrai que quand j'allais à
l'école je faisais 7 kilomètres sur le
chemin pour aller à l'école et 7 km pour
le retour donc je souffrais beaucoup de
ne pas être comme mes petits camarades
et d'avoir des chaussures et puis il n'y
avait pas très loin de chez nous une
femme qu'on appelait la louise et qui
est et ce qu'on appelait une absente qui
était de plus sur terre mais au ciel
cette femme je vais aller un jour comme
ça je savais où elle planqué son argent
et je lui ai piqué 50 francs sous ses
draps pour acheter un personnage au
sérieux voilà ouais donc on m'a changé
de famille ensuite j'ai fait cette
famille comme ça dix mois il ya quelques
années il ya moins de dix ans quand tu
as vu arriver jean-luc la caisse comment
tu as vécu ça jean luc a eu sa mère et a
connu son père jean-luc était haut comme
ça quand j'étais moi grand comme ça ça
vincent de paul vous connaissiez en tous
les cas je les bien appuyé quand il est
arrivé parce qu'il nous faut a été
jaloux de lui je vois pas l'intérêt tu
sais quand on a quelqu'un de sa famille
et consente un mec
dans la vie on va s'en sortir on a
plutôt envie de donner plutôt fier papa
génie non non j'ai plutôt été fier à
l'époque où tu es tu donnes et où tu
fugué comme ça tu allais les foire du
trône bien entendu j'avais surtout la
foire du trône est ce qu'elle est là je
bouffais l'oeil
tu connais irta la femme la plus grosse
du monde j'en ai entendu parler
regarde hertha est une femme comblée
elle est mariée mère de famille possède
une poitrine à faire pâlir d'envié mais
ouest et elle est le dernier vrai
phénomène de la foire du trône
tout cela yorkton le doit qu'à elle-même
car elle n'a jamais rien demandé à
personne pas même à sa très influente
cousine la secrétaire d'état chargée des
droits de la femme et de la consommation
véronique neiertz parce que mon grand
père avait réussi mon qui lui à une
échelle qui s'est marié avec véronique
lavoie dont qui est maintenant véronique
n'est hertz et puis aussi d'un usage ma
mère qui se bat avec un foret kim a eu
un mois
c'est donc à sa mère qui retarde doit
son illustre cousine mais sans robert un
outil le ferait un joli coeur la femme
la plus grosse du monde ne serait pas à
la foire du trône bien maman m'a raconté
donc quand elle
elle est venue sur la fête la fête du
trône qui se trouve en ce moment là à
nation et puis mon père victor retourner
dans la boue l'infernal erreur d'être
amoureuse de mon père parce qu'ils à la
parade
c'était une grande histoire d'amour
ils se sont mariés ils ont eu trois
enfants ça n'a pas tellement été
acceptée par les foraine en quelque
sorte en était très très réticente sur
la venue de jeanne et l'attitude et
qu'elles ont adopté c'est de l'ignorer
totalement avec le ton et la naissance
de ses enfants la présence de la mère
dire tu as finalement admise est
aujourd'hui l'histoire de jeunes et de
robert n'est plus qu'une romance parmi
les souvenirs des vieux fera le parrain
de la foire du trône 1992 se montre
pourtant sceptiques sur les origines
dire tu as c'est la cousine de véronique
meyer très bien mais remarquer véronique
meyer c'est le ministre des femmes
elle peut être aussi aux ministres des
grosses femmes je lui demanderai la
prochaine fois que gérard dîner à
l'elysée si elle y est elles seront
assez sûr car à l'elysée comme chez les
forains on ne manque pas les fêtes de
famille
cousine de véronique meyer s de l'info
est de l'intox
hervé vilard à l'oreille ouais alors
mesdames messieurs pendant que vous
demandez c'est de l'info ou si c'est de
l'intox pendant que vous tapez sur votre
minitel pendant que nana mouskouri et
mireille mathieu réfléchisse qu'est ce
qu'on écoute corte sortie ben quoi bein
1990 c'était l'heure de la communication
92 aussi alors je fais comme jean leloup
sauf que lui il est dans la playlist de
double jeu ouais je vais vous faire une
chanson le sujet en est ambitieux de mon
image je suis soucieux en 1990 c'est
l'heure des communications
il s
chez ma mère
diable
toi
je
ça
m
hissène
c'est la vraie conscientisation
[Musique]
la fois
aux soldats américains
français
ce qui nivelait les chances
en revanche
je n'ai jamais
on se passer
dans chaque sens
attend d'eux
bruno cousine de véronique meyer s de
l'info est de l'intox toi de jouer nana
d'une taxe intox pourquoi tout ça une
idée une idée des toits mireille pour
m'amuser c'est bien faux j'ai dit que
c'est de l'info oui toi et revêtu m'a
dit que c'était de l'intox
et ouais bon écoute l'expert philippe
gas et oui bravo bravo à hervé vous
commencé fort puisque c'était totalement
de l'intox
tu es un commentaire mon fils ou oui mon
gros j'ai un commentaire commence par un
philippin oui mon mec chez un
commentaire c'est dommage qu'ils retard
et que véronique neiertz ne soit pas de
la même famille
elle pourrait de temps en temps échanger
leur place avec sa dignité sa
gentillesse et son humour irta ferait un
très très bon ministre
quant à véronique meyer de sa compagne
et de sa responsable de la communication
elle ferait toutes les deux un très très
beau phénomène de foire
c'est bien tout de suite le rang on n'en
parle pas mon dieu comme patient voix
qu'on entend les tacles pour ce qui est
du score tu veux tu veux le sco bas le
score encore parler facile 1 0 pour le
sandwich grec
bravo
dix mois en camp tu as eu ton certificat
d'études ouais tu es parti à paris oui
tu arrivé à pigalle
oui et tu as vécu dans un drôle de
milieu qu'on maintenant dans tous les
milieux on n'en parle pas on n'en parle
pas tu dis si j'avais pas être et
chanteur je serais devenu voyous mais
j'étais voyous att voyons oui qu'est ce
tu faisais tout j'ai servilité chez ces
dames
ah bon oui as-tu servait avoirs sont
gelés il va ma fille va s'amuser gel et
ma fille on n'en parle pas pas fier
j'allais acheter les perruques faire
coiffer les peru j'allais acheter les
bacs avait fuit faire j'sais pas quoi me
remettre les bas qui avait filé quelques
mac aussi me donner quelques courses à
quelques trucs comme ça mais c'était un
certain enfin à l'époque c'était un
curieux métier parce que un petit
curieux milieu pardon ma vie je vais pas
fait c'est pas été jusque là mais je
veux dire c'était un curieux milieu
parce que il y avait vraiment une
profonde tendresse en ce qui me concerne
c'est quand je me sentais comme protégé
qu'est ce que tu as fait de pire à ce
moment là j'ai fait des tas de choses
le pire que ma fille est capable de
faire ouais
104 vous là quelque chose qui est en
train de naître ce soir passion
est-ce beaucoup et on n'en parle pas
parce que tu as fait de pire dur le truc
le pire que t'es fait à ce moment-là
c'est ce que j'ai dû faire dès
maintenant j'ai dû piquer des ddd disque
dans les magasins j'allais pas très loin
mais toews et à faire le sac de ces
dames qu'en même temps n'ont jamais été
jusque là j'avais des copains qui
étaient des proxénètes
ouais et alors là tu as fait un disque
non c'est à l'époque où tu étais chez
vendeur chez les do musique que tu as
fait ton premier disque en premier
disque à moi ouais mon premier disque à
moi s'appelait une voix qui t'appelle
les savanes est toujours c'est un une
chanson prédestiné c'était une chanson
comme ça qu'ils lançaient un appel en
dix ans il te semble entendre dans la
brume de tes rêves
une voix qui t'appelle une voix qui
t'appelle c'était un petit peu
autobiographique
tu n'as jamais chanté ça je les fais
rare pour ce disque j'ai dû chanter une
fois la télévision mais on m'a pas
engagé beaucoup
alors après il capri c'est fini dont
j'ai crié par le la musique parce que
j'en avais marre qu'on me présente des
chansons américaines dont il faille des
adaptations et tout et tout seules
paroles et musique / caprices et j'ai
écrit les paroles et la musique et je
les fais mettre en mesure à un musicien
parce qu'il faut dire que je joue du
piano sur deux doigts et comment tu as
eu cette idée comment cette mélodie
était venu elle m'est venue avec la rage
cette l'envi il fallait absolument que
j'y arrive parce que sinon j'y
retournais tout droit 60 pages web et
puis un jour j'ai vu dans le métro écrit
sur une pub comme ça partait en vacances
à capri pour 2000 francs il y avait à
l'époque une chanson de d'aznavour que
j'aimais beaucoup ça plaît c'est fini
fini fini
et puis j'écoutais beaucoup de chansons
françaises je me nourrissais beaucoup de
flammes comme aujourd'hui et j'ai joint
les deux tu as eu cette grosse
inspiration cette fois là mais après
comment ça se fait que tu aies fait plus
de l'adaptation que de que de création
parce qu'ensuite tu es le succès est
venu et la première fois on m'a annoncé
que j'étais numéro un on a ça m'a fait
aucun effet mais après il a fallu
rentrer dans la compétition et apprendre
son métier et tu en vendée 2000 par jour
c'était incroyable quand même un peu
plus même un peu plus de même disons 10
mille feux a vendu 11 millions
oui tu le sais ça oui un peu plus mais
ça rapporte combien parents encore
qu'après je sais pas mais droits
d'auteur sont bien élevés au rouge pas
une vingtaine de briques par an a quand
même et c'est à cette époque que tu as
retrouvé ta mère que tu es devenu
célèbre le journal france dimanche là la
retrouver l'ami dans une chambre d'hôtel
toi on t'a fait on attendu que tu
reviennes de ta tournée des moments où
tu es rentré dans la chambre il ya des
dizaines de photographes qui sont sortis
des placards tain ça dure ça quand même
dans ses dribbles
je suis entré dans cette chambre d'hôtel
maman était là assise comme ça et à ce
moment là et les portes de placards des
portes de machin qui sont ouvertes
partout et les flashs partout en fait
c'était assez horrible tu leur en veux
pas non maintenant puisque tu continues
à travailler avec eux j'ai toujours des
articles sur toile en france dimanche
ça on n'y peut rien alors là il n'y a
rien à faire moi je ne refuse pas je
n'accepte pas où je laisse faire
en même temps quand j'ai une fille en
cédant que je découvre dans france
dimanche
j'en suis ravi tout va bien et on n'en
parle pas tamer donc tu l'as tu
l'envoyer chez le coiffeur tu lui a loué
un appartement qu'est ce que tu as fait
quand tu la retrouves est on ne décide
pas y en aurait fait pas la vie de
quelqu'un à 60 ans a essayé de soissons
j'ai essayé de beaucoup de m'occuper
d'eux moment où elle a beaucoup
culpabilisé et ça n'a pas réussi
un jour tu as reçu un petit bout de gens
de propriano en corse il n'y a pas très
longtemps
ouais ouais te disant votre père est ici
est en fait il était là mais
malheureusement été l'a enterré là où
est en fait c'est quelqu'un qui
s'appelait baglioni c'est ça oui qui
était venu à paris mais qui avait fait
un enfant à ta mère oui mais qui était
marié encore et qui retournait en corse
en laissant ta mère seule oui y'a rien à
rajouter
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après capri
c'est fini tu sais tu as quand même ça
tournait la tête ça parce qu'après il ya
eu un sacré trou combat
il ya aidés des chansons que j'ai écrit
avec danyel gérard wey fait là rires
comme vous vivent
ouais mais qu'ils étaient des chansons
qui ne correspondaient pas tellement
finalement au style de l'époque
ouais et le suicide alors c'est à quelle
époque cette tentative de suicide c'est
du bidon
bah écoute c'est du bidon il y en a
plein les journaux de l'époque ça c'est
pas mon truc je ne suis jamais j'ai
jamais fait une tentative de suicide
non tout ça c'était monté pour la presse
avec ton accord non j'ai fait une lourde
dépression nerveuse
c'est à dire tout ce que j'avais
accumulé en très peu de temps et d'y
rentrer 18 ans et 22 ans
c'était trop tu dis quand même à c'est
une déclaration de toi entre guillemets
dans un journal à l'époque tu dis je
suis un produit de consommation dont
plus personne ne veut
j'ai dit sam way à l'époque je disais à
l'époque c'est pas moi qui ai parlé la
séparant attribuer des phrases entre
guillemets qui ne prononçait pas bah ça
se fait encore beaucoup aujourd'hui oui
quand même
ouais ben oui bloquer les prix des
barbituriques ah oui tu sois dit non non
mais je te demande tu sais pas non j'ai
pas plus le tarif biture hic
un soir on va regarder un sujet alors
prends ton petit téléviseur c'est une
histoire de barbituriques juge à abattre
c'est donc on fait l'enchaînement
j'étais fait d'accord
allons-y portes closes et rideau de fer
sauf à paris où quelques pharmacies
reste ouverte voilà ce que l'on trouve
la nuit quand on a besoin d'un
médicament
alors pourquoi pas un distributeur
automatique de médicaments cette
expérience a été tentée par michel
pasquet pharmacienne à melun en décembre
1991 fr 3 ile de france lui a consacré
un reportage melun dispose aujourd'hui
d'un distributeur automatique de
médicaments en vente libre grâce à
l'initiative d'une pharmacienne michel
pasquier
si moi j'ai constaté une baisse de
chiffre d'affaires est une bonne idée
la qualité
super centre habilité
attendent assis pendant les
les heures de fermeture
je pense que j'agis pour la latérite vie
là on n'a pas de racines la nuit
pourquoi pas ça peut soulager de
monsieur cas très mal aux dents
s'appelle d'engins
neuf mois plus tard plus de
distributeurs à la porte de la pharmacie
de madame pasquet que s'est il passé à
deux semaines après la mise en place du
distributeur j'ai eu la visite de
l'inspecteur en pharmacie qui m'a dressé
un procès verbal se référant à l'article
tél 519 et l 581 du code de la santé
publique m obligeant ainsi à retirer
l'appareil
cette interdiction est justifiée car ce
mode de distribution est contraire au
code de la santé publique qui stipule
que seul un pharmacien peut délivrer un
médicament au public
prenons le cas d'un médicament castelli
qui se trouvait dans le distributeur le
guronsan le malade qui aurait à suivre
un régime des sondés ne doit pas prendre
ce médicament
s'ils veulent acheter régulièrement à la
pharmacie le pharmacien va établir un
dialogue
il lui a dit qu'eads interrompre ce
traitement alors que les distributeurs
restera muet indifférent ouais ils ont
raison d'interdire quoi laisser c'était
interdit c'est sans doute une question
de fric là dedans c'est un monopole
comme un autre que quelque part
remy battu en brèche et puis voilà quoi
les monopoles ça te sens toujours la
route
c'est dommage parce que ça rendait
vraiment service aux gens c'est
illogique aussi parce qu'il ya des
mairies buteur automatique légalement de
préservatifs de serviettes périodiques
dans les hôtels pour les jeunes femmes
ou de médicament très simple on peut
acheter où on veut de la vitamine c o
des pansements là maintenant on est
obligé d'aller réveiller les flics qui
eux mêmes vont réveiller le pharmacien
qui va vous vendre un produit que
j'aurais pu acheter
normalement aux heures ouvrables
21 vitesse de l'info est honnête homme
car deyvillers à l'oreille ouais
alors mesdames messieurs pendant que
vous vous demandez si c'est de l'info si
c'est de l'intox
pendant que nana mouskouri et mireille
mathieu réfléchissent qu'est-ce qu'on
écoute partie au moins batman ouais
lorsque je me repose lorsque je ne
protège pas votre ville contre la
méchante joker qu'est ce que j'écoute
les blatter de great pretender
car attention là
oh oui
k
je pense
durée
nle
ok
tu
alors
pas le calcaire
oui
tél
et le point
c'est fait
ok
mathieu
ils veulent
m
avec tout ça
fidèle des combats qui ont fait rage
quelque 6
c'est sûr
m
standing d'avion
à
et
il est supérieur
tom et cinématiques interdite est-ce de
l'info s de l'intox mirail à toi de
jouer
stoxx intox pourquoi j'irais de m'amuser
ah oui d'accord il veut gagner l'or aux
barres we will hunt occidentaux si hervé
tum a dit que c'était de l'intox un bon
bagage acquis bonnet d'âne pour physique
d'une écoute experts voient là puisque
je me suis fait planter par trois
personnes
c'est de l'intox oh on a vu qu'on en
parlait pas à vous excuser moi on n'en
parle pas bon alors est-ce que tu as un
commentaire maintenant oui mon petit y
ériger un commentaire cette histoire
était totalement fausse un distributeur
automatique de médicaments y compris de
médicaments sans ordonnance c'est
totalement interdit en france et c'est
pas près de changer puisque en france à
cause de l'église et de certains
syndicats on prend les consommateurs en
parfaite santé pour des cons en leur
interdisant d'acheter des disques y
compris les rvs evilard le dimanche je
ne vois donc pas pourquoi le lobby des
pharmaciens autoriserait les
consommateurs ayant mal à la tête a
trouvé de l'aspirine en pleine nuit
ça serait pas logique or l'applaudît par
ex
le score 2-1 pour la chanteuse lennik à
sa fait 2 pour les nie tout
alors
maintenant tout va bien impeccable t'as
pu besoin de d'attachée de presse pour
te monte des faux suicide t'as pu besoin
de ça pour être rechargée attachée de
presse pour me monter des faux suicide
mais j'ai besoin d'attaché de presse qui
gagnent leur vie
ouais alors ma mamie est au top 50
oui tu es content très content alors
maintenant on va faire pascal sevran
ar je suis que c'est ma nouvelle idée
mais j'ai dîné avec lui l'autre jour il
m'a dit tu faire dix ans j'avais oui
t'as pas peur je suis le nom maintenant
balas on en parle beaucoup mais pas de
côté alors moi je suis pascal sevran
ouais et toi tu es le jukebox d'accord
allons-y quand tu vas nous les faire les
uns après les autres n'en parlent pas ma
fille alors moi je veux surtout capri
c'est fini pour le pan pan pan
nous dirons plus jamais où tu m'as dit
je t'aime ne verront plus jamais tu
viens de décider nous n'irons plus
jamais ce soir c'est plus la peine ne
lirons plus jamais comme les autres
années capri
c'est fini et que c'était la ville de
mon premier amour
capri c'est fini
je ne crois pas que j'y retournerai un
jour
merci d'en faire une chanson
une chanson que tu as fais juste après
qu'a prit donc qui s'appelle fait
derrière que j'aime beaucoup ça me
rappelle quand j'étais jeune quand tu
étais jeune voilà c'était disc-jockey
gelant les pins whisky à gogo
alors puisque ton coeur a su d'enlever à
mon coeur que malgré mon amour le tien
n'avait pas peur tâche est donc
maintenant à force de les lire d'effacer
tout ça vit tout le mal que j'ai fait
c'est lary c'est là rires c'est la vie
pour elle tout peut recommencer ferrari
fait là rires fera rire de joindre joint
fait la chanter
sur l'album sur le cd du théâtre des
variétés
oui et que j'avais pas entendu depuis
l'époque et s'il monte donc j'aimerais
bien que tu veux je la chante en italien
ah oui si c'est possible non c'est un
entièrement rénové open c'est toi tu es
ou aperto you keep et warda victor noir
et un top manager laval mundo comme s&p
j'irai monde odile en scène sa fille
l'iconia money conduit à moriat penalty
qu'ont lieu mohammedia finity comme la
joy comme dans l'ordre et la jane c'est
quand même est il mort on au sol tantôt
s'orienter bordeaux n'ont ni le taux
oscille entre rien n'y fait
aux sonorités à cannes 3 t
merci merci beaucoup
le faire nous en serbo-croate s'appelait
ça viendra cette folle menace si tu peux
arrêter maintenant est ce que tu aurais
de quoi vivre jusqu'à la fin de tes
jours où est-ce que c'est pas possible
non on botte de punk et lui a donné la
réponse non c'est impossible ça un peu
alors j'ai lu récemment dans france soir
là tu me dira peut-être que c'est encore
les journalistes qu'ils envient françois
jolly france soir bien sûr une chance tu
es et tu disais il y avait un article
sur toi et je pas si c'est vrai enfin tu
disais que tu es le tino rossi de l'an
j'ai lancé une boutade comme ça j'ai
bien connu tino tino qui était un être
charmant est vraiment exceptionnel et je
pense souvent à lui 1 et j'ai lancé à
catherine delmas effectivement je vais
parce qu'elle m'a dit mais tu te rends
compte qui t'arrive 27 ans de carrière
top 50
tu as les albums d'or et je lui ai dit
mais chérie je suis le tino rossi de
l'an 2000 bon je vais voir on verra bien
on va voir on revient on va voir tout de
suite on va voir tout de suite lambin fi
co star
qui sait
c'est alain chamfort
et puis souvent mais je le connais je le
connais je le connais je le connais je
le connais ce qui est aux enfants
agnel
balavoine
je le connais ce petit ce petit jeune
jeune mais ça c'est beaucoup plus jeune
mais il n'a pas tellement changé
vous savez qui c'est oui tu vois comment
il s'appelle un adamo adamois
ce n'est pas ça
l'assemblée a trop
après après l'accident de voiture
un visage il a eu un accident de voiture
six mois merci moi maintenant il est
comme ça bon là on s'assure toledo
je vois bien méchant bien il va bien
c'est trop baissé c'est via vous le
trouvez plus beau maintenant ou avant je
voulais faire avant les succès
dites lui parce qu'ils vous regardent et
demi madame vous êtes très beau
maintenant comme ça des clés vous êtes
autre beau mâle tonneau c'est bon
science merci adamo
cherche je cherche je cherche je cherche
non pas tellement les chanteurs moderne
du lepa moderne madame il est ringard
c'est pas son nom de star
oui mais j'arrive pas un jeu je l'avalé
vous le connaissez vous bien non mais je
t'ai connu
j'ai un trou vous voyez le connaître
non non non j'en ai vu à le trouver
c'est papa
c'est ton papa st
bonjour je ne sais pas quoi dire
michel
déjà les fûts
pascal store alors bien sûr on a monté
que les gens qui se souvenait plus mais
il ya plein plein de gens qui s'en
souviennent plus je pourrai pas moins
jeu je le dis très sincèrement quand il
va trop loin comme ça des fois mais je
zappe
ah bon ouais quand il chante pardon moi
aussi je serai maison
dis moi tu as eue dans ta vie des hauts
et des bas oui hein donc on va te faire
une interview à bandal tu es prêt le
plus grand moment de sa vie où il y en a
eu mais je crois que l'un des plus beaux
tous les cas c'est le roux tu sens la
liberté où tu sens que tu vas partir
avec quelque chose c'est le jour où j'ai
signé mon premier contrat hier le
contrat de disque et le pire moment de
ta vie le pire je ne sais pas moi qui
passe est maintenant en pas du tout pas
du tout je suis très très bien
j'ai quelques petites appréhensions
avant de venir mais il ya eu à un moment
enfin parlons de mon métier c'est le
jour où les astronautes sont arrivés
dans la lune mais n'en parle pas et
j'étais couché comme ça ça oui dans un
décor
fecamp
c'est un déconneur c'est là et alors il
y avait un décor lunaire est on est on
voulait me faire chanter par terre pour
c'était une émission de télé dimanche y
est je me suis planté quoi carrément je
chantais côté de la mesure
c'est un des pires moments parce que
côté en direct comme ça ton plus gros
coup de fric
ma ford mustang ah ouais ouais j'ai vu à
quel âge j'avais pas mon permis de
conduire
il fallait que je m'en sorte quoi alors
j'avais j'étais encore mineure et l'état
prenait mon argent alors parce qu'on
avait mis tout ça sur des livrets de
caisse d'epargne temps et j'étais
pupille de la nation alors un moment je
suis sorti on m'a dit vous avez gagné
tant en est quand j'ai fait je suis
sorti sur les champs-elysées il y avait
la première ford mustang décapotable à
paris j'ai fait je veux ça ouais ouais
c'est la plus grosse perte de fric il y
en a un petit peu là mais bon on va pas
se plaindre et je suis pas là pour
pour me plaindre mais j'ai j'en ai
bouffé pas mal ouais j'en aime et puis
tant mieux comment on l'a fait en vivant
missionnaire en vivant alors je t'ai vu
l'autre jour chez jacques martin à
l'école des fans
ouais et les gagnants avaient droit à un
petit bracelet en deux ans ouais marc
hervé vilard d'un côté avec leur nom ils
pouvaient faire graver leur nom de
l'autre ne trouve pas ça mignon de
senozan un peu démago enfin dumas
puisqu'il est démagogique à offrir une
gourmette en or à un enfant de 5 ans et
tu disais que certains sont devenus
grands parce qu'elles ont tant que tu
peux l'école des fans ont débattu
rencontre des commerçants et des chars
en garde sont dans la rue ouais il te
montre ça fait six mois que je vous
parle de sextant pas mais je pourrais
être père de famille il ya il n'y a
jamais eu de produire bévilard s'il y en
a dia quoi qu'il ya des pimms de toi il
ya des primes si à des briques et il ya
des t-shirts l'été des t-shirts hiver si
j'ai les produits je vais te montrer
quelque chose regarde
city
cet hiver
hélas
[Musique]
mais si mal
m
diffusé par erreur dans double jeu s de
l'info s de l'intox
hervé vilard alors est-ce de l'info
temps qui arrive de l'école quoi tu vas
papier nous vaincrons qui s'est rien
passé tu t'es planté je te signale alors
vie je me suis planté on arrête les
magnétos recommence tout enfin laurence
et mon émission j en suis responsable a
rien là bas si je veux mettre ma femme
et je mets ma femme
ok mais tu la mets chez toi
installé depuis quelques années à paris
les boutiques l'offre cherche à imposer
un raffinement sobre c'est ainsi que
l'oft a choisi d'appeler jack sa
nouvelle eau de toilette un prénom
symbole de l'homme cultivé et moderne
la senteur un mélange boisé le flacon et
les étiquettes sont prêts reste à lancer
le produit on devait faire une campagne
sur le lancement de parfums campagne qui
est toujours pas arrêté en fait avec
peut-être un visuel montrant le profil
de jack lang est toujours est il que
jack lang a eu a eu vent de cette de
cette éventuelle campagne et on a reçu
un beau jour une assignation devant le
tribunal de grande instance de paris
pour utilisation abusive de l'image et
de la notoriété d'un homme public à des
fins commerciales
mais jack lang schnock jack kerouac ou
encore jack nicholson il s'approprie
deux faits l'exclusivité de son prénom
en portant l'affairé devant les
tribunaux
sans son accord bien entendu et à des
fins mercantiles
a fortiori il est hors de question que
quiconque utilise le nom du mise
nous voulons simplement faire suspendre
la vente de ses produits de ces deux
parfums dans le circuit des magasins en
question
si la ministre obtient satisfaction dix
mille flacons seront détruits et ce
serait une véritable catastrophe
financière
l'oft essaye donc actuellement de
négocier avec jack lang afin de
l'associer pleinement au lancement de
jack quand on lance un parfum de star
il faut assurer la promo derrière sou
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il ya beaucoup de
parfums de stars qui se casse la figure
il faut que la star vient de fada
présence aux carrières paient tous les
points de vente qu'elle soit là pour les
admirateurs de ses admiratrices
et donc si on n'est pas assuré de ce
service
j'ai suivi ses pas sûr que ça marche
donc qu'est-ce que ce parfumeur peut
compter sur l'appui de sa star c'est une
itt c'est ça le problème
moi je pense qu'il peut y compter mais
dans un an puisque rami sera plus
ministre il aura du temps pourra le
garder à la fia de faire la promotion de
ses portes
le fabricant du parfum jake hess de
l'info s de l'intox
hervé vilard à l'oreille ouais alors
mesdames messieurs pendant que vous
demandez si c'est de l'info ou si c'est
de l'intox
pendant que nana mouskouri et mireille
mathieu réfléchissent qu'est-ce qu'on
écoute corti tout à fait thierry foule
faire une bonne chanson fell d'abord
quid la soupe à minneapolis
et puis éplucher le verre de lunettes
enfin et cuisses eu c'est un geste de
prince et envoyé baltique à martigues 4
kitchen
[Musique]
quebecor
b
[Musique]
kate
g
m
[Musique]
il
chez
gas
[Musique]
je suis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes fatigués
hier
je vis terre
[Musique]
m
volley
[Musique]
jack
en justice le fabricant du parfum jake
hess de l'info est de l'intox nana à toi
de jouer
je dirais de l'intox pourquoi c'est
parait bizarre très drôle paraît bizarre
oui oui oui je n'ai pas les coupant la
presse intox
je peux le dire et villard m'a dit que
c'était de l'info oui bon c'est un
ministre ouais ben on regarde on écoute
l'expert philippe gas et oui c'est un
ministre mais nous nous sommes des
menteurs puisque c'était de l'intox
est-ce que tu as un commentaire ma
grosse on n'en parle pas on n'en parle
pas allés est-ce que tu as un
commentaire filou oui thierry chez un
commentaire je tiens à remercier la
boutique loft de nous avoir accueillis
est comme gelée promis je préciserai
qu'ils ne veulent aucun mal à jack lang
je répète aucun mal à jack lang par
ailleurs au patron de cette boutique
comme prévu toute l'équipe de double jeu
sera bien mardi prochain j'aurai pas à
maghama prochain on veut dire essayer la
garde-robe complète je répète lagarde
laurent hava complète qui l'a gentiment
décidé nous offrir à chacun de nous
l'expert
eh bien décidément pas du tout lé là
mondiale d'avignon n'a plus qu'un jeu
pour faire son retard car elle est
toujours mené deux à trois par nana
mouskouri ces derniers sprints
politiquement tu te situes ou libérale
libéral
ouais parce que je me souviens d'une
histoire de ne pas nous raconter
l'histoire de du gala l'hippodrome là
pour les communistes je mal passé je
suis pas un anti communiste prix là on à
ce jour là ils n'ont pas à me cru alors
ses erreurs
ça va pas être trop long mais j'aimerais
puisqu'on a dit qu'on racontait tout on
raconte plus on avait justement alors tu
t'es fait siffler tu t'es fait huer pas
du tout pas du temps les jeunes prévenus
dont l'antenne
non non non non les jeunes à chanter
quand même moment les gens étaient venus
pour chanter nous revient capri y avait
des mamans avec des poussettes et des
enfants c'était une fête à politique
jusqu'en 80 ouais
ces gens là avaient bien
préparé leur coup ouais est bon alors
les types ensuite sont arrivés en sortie
des fausses idées marteau sont jeté des
cailloux sur les sur les choristes
par-derrière assez comme ça alors ça ça
un petit peu dégénéré mais les gens
continuent à chanter nous vient et capri
c'est fini et il est évident qu'à la fin
je suis parti en très vite après avoir
fait mon temps mais tu as fait ton temps
ailleurs
et ces gens là non le type qui avait
délibérément retourné sa veste a décidé
pas nous payer oui il ya eu procès et
nous les avons attaqués nous avons gagné
nous avons eu des excuses du paradis eux
depuis tout va bien mais toi tu es
plutôt chiraquiens comme maintenant non
je suis pas je suis fier de paris est
amer et que ce soit jacques chirac
ouais je suis très content mais j'aime
beaucoup président mitterrand aussi moi
je suis assez tu sait jamais j'avais
beaucoup la cohabitation
parce que je trouvais que ça les motive
et l'un et l'autre et c'est bien pour
notre notre pays ça peut recommencer
ailleurs marc hein
alors comment ça peut être tant mieux
plus un mélange plus on est bien wii wii
fit ça n'a rien à voir avec ma fille
j'ai pas du tout envie de me mélanger
avec baffie ah bon voilà bah il est très
déçu pas fait dix mois une cité
chiraquien faut le dire je ne sais pas
un tas pas avoir honte d'être chiraquien
l'époux prêche ça c'est comme le reste
tu sais c'est comme le reste on n'en
parle pas on avait voilà j'aime beaucoup
les gens comme ferrat et tout ça mais
sont quand même des gens qui ont pris
position au départ avant de devenir des
artistes et c'est pas parce que soudain
tout d'un coup on a une notoriété comme
sa populaire qu'il faut aller
brandir des étendards je suis pas
tellement d'accord sur l'europe
oui c'est vrai je suis acharné as tu
acharnée dans quelle chance je suis pour
donc tu prend parti pour l'europe je
pense que l'europe est un rempart et
c'est en tous les cas en europe
l'annonciation de la paix bon ben
regarde parce que tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord avec toi tant pis mais moi
je suis cet avis-là lors des dernières
élections législatives au royaume uni en
écosse le parti national écossais
étaient donnés favoris
d'après un sondage 40 % de la population
était favorable à l'indépendance atouts
maîtres du snp son membre le plus récent
et le plus célèbre sean connery
l'illustrent stars du grand écran le
héros de films tels que le nom de la
rose
indiana jones et la dernière croisade
ainsi que des premiers james bond
[Musique]
je crois qu'il n'y a personne d'autre en
accord ce qui est du standing de
championnat ceci étant dit nous avons
beaucoup d'artistes d'écossé qui nous
soutiennent sur numéro deux de son
numéro d'adhésion 004 effet vers véro
faible il adhère officiellement au parti
en janvier 1992 et depuis il n'a jamais
cessé de lui apporter son soutien dans
la bataille pour l'indépendance de
l'ecosse il a prêté sa voix pour les
spots de propagande
il a aussi depuis sa villa de marbella
en espagne dénoncer je cite le
terrorisme verbal de ceux qui pensent
que cette indépendance ne serait pas
viable
je pense pas qu'on puisse parler
surprise pour renouer d'abord parce
qu'il a toujours dit très engagé aux
côtés des écossais et puis il ya une
tradition dans les pays anglo saxons de
l'engagement des comédiens il ya
l'exemple de vanessa redgrave par
exemple qui est très engagée en grande
bretagne où clint eastwood rappelez-vous
qui a pris la mairie de carmel vaut aux
états unis mais c'est un petit peu le
même genre de réflexe anglo saxons donc
découvrir aujourd'hui à sean connery
plus militant qu'on pouvait l'imaginer
c'est assez bien dans l'ordre des choses
malgré l'emploi du temps chargé de sean
connery membres c'est 0-0 c'est du snp
le parti lui rend compte en permanence
de ses activités certainement afin
qu'ils n'oublient pas d'acquitter chaque
année le montant de sa cotisation
[Musique]
shenzhen
la l'indépendance de l'ecosse s de
l'info s de l'intox
hervé vilard al rai ouais mesdames
messieurs quand vous demandez c'est de
l'info si c'est de l'intox
pendant que nana mouskouri et mireille
mathieu réfléchisse qu'est ce qu'on
écoute philippe corti relation tu peu
embêté parce que en fait je voulais
lancer avec la pta shot the sheriff est
d'ailleurs ce qui tombe à chaud de
poulet ça veut rien dire autant pour les
châteaux chéri
je ne sais pas
c
[Musique]
auj
m
[Musique]
ces jeux
non
[Musique]
je l'aï fait
m
mais ce cas
tous nos voeux
[Musique]
oui
c'est cher
[Musique]
m
la ccima
[Musique]
je
vous verrez
m
comme je tenais
sean coyle
dépendance de l'ecosse s de l'info s de
l'intox mirail à toi de jouer
intox intox pourquoi je pense que les
cinémas les vins certainement mieux
ouais que la politique in touch
intox si toi tu m'as dit que c'était de
l'intox st je refuse de croire qu'un
homme qui a vu le monde se réfugie dans
une petite parcelle comme ça dont on
écoute l'expert qui libyen
hervé hervé pour cette dernière question
je vous propose un petit si vous avez
répondu fausse que vous accepteriez de
chanter une petite chanson une dernière
petite nous nous danois et ça tombe bien
parce que vous avez perdu c'était de
l'info est-ce que tu as commentaires ont
fait nous c'est de l'info et tout cela
c'est uniquement parce qu'il s'appelle
sean connery que l'on parle autant de
l'indépendance de l'ecosse
tenez moi philippe guérin si je
demandais l'indépendance du 10e
arrondissement personne n'en aurait rien
à [ __ ] alors que pour sean connery
je me demande si c'est à cause de son
prénom ou de son nom qu'autant de gens
le suivent
alors avant de
le score alors en baffie on a écouté de
nous mais ça me fait très plaisir
un but a perdu là sur ce coup alors on
t'écoute
il faut que je chante comme ça a
cappella encore si je viens à leurs
jours et filets de réponse
alors si nous c'est une illusion qui
meurent d'un éclat de rire en plein
coeur une histoire de rien du tout comme
il y en existe beaucoup notre mot qu'on
croyait petit a grandi quand tu es parti
grandi comme une déchirure comme une
blessure mais pourquoi peau tu veux te
façon un peu encore la belge elle
reprendra pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi le
silence
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi ce grand vide quand je pense à
lui
très bien m j'espère éclaté
sur cette chanson s'était dit il dédié
c'est prenant c'est un portois alors
vas-y maintenant mais le score est bien
écoute c'est bien simple la môme y
attend chez la mongolie
regarde bien maintenant nana les cadeaux
qui défilent sont en petit téléviseur et
tu me dis celui que tu veux nm ou 5 1
[Musique]
dupont dans son programme la chaîne hifi
colonnes elle comprend un cd
programmable à l'ampli turbo basse
générateur un tuner une double platine
k7 autoreverse bravo nadal à plat
alors maintenant à hervé je vais te
demander de te lever tu vas aller vers
le fauteuil qui est là bas et au moment
où tu vas t'asseoir sur ce fauteuil il
va te poser la question qu'est ce que je
faisais en fauteuil il faut que tu y
ailles allons-y
or 12 la quelle est la chose dont on est
parent n'est pas lé front national eh
ben on continue qu'est ce qu'on est bien
là voilà tu es mieux là impeccable lors
du mois grâce à patrick sabatier
oui il faut le dire quand même oui
miracle oui tu as pu rencontrer le pape
oui comment ça s'est passé
il est venu vers moi j'ai lu des prêches
que je les emmenais de la baie en grand
il a salué 250 personnes il est revenu
vers moi et m'a dit est ce que nous
pouvons nous rencontrer cet après midi
dans un parfait français
ouais j'avais les jambes qui flageolent
est et je lui ai dit oui et je suis allé
dans son jardin et j'ai vu que l'après
midi un homme en chine
angel ouais le pape ça existe le pape
aussi mais une salopette de jardinier ah
bon voilà faisait parler de quoi
on a parlé de choses qui ne te regarde
pas ah ben oui pendant 25 minutes
absolument
tu vas me dire un petit peu pendant la
confession quand même mais pas sur le
pape est bon ben je te dirai ce qu'il a
à dire d'accord tu me suis hervé vilard
es-tu favorable au divorce ou non je
pense que c'est une déchirure quelque
part qui n'est pas nécessaire es-tu
favorables à l'avortement
je ne suis pas favorable à l'avortement
à l'homosexualité
je ne suis pas défavorable
je suis favorable à l'homosexualité à la
peine de mort alors là non c'est
impossible de vouloir là quoi qu'il ait
fait de vouloir la mort de quelqu'un
[Musique]
même pour les assassins d'enfants
oui parce que dieu est le seul juge
duval à metz oui tous les dimanches non
j'y vais quand quand j'en ai envie
quand j'ai envie d'aller à la rencontre
des autres parce qu'elle est la messe
c'est aussi cela est-ce que tu
communiques quand tu vas à la messe
pas régulièrement mais au minimum une
fois par an se procure quad communion
c'est quelque chose de très personnel
c'est une histoire c'est une affaire
entre dieu et moi j'aime bien m'entendre
avec dieu je m'entends très bien avec
lui tu lui parles bien sûr tu lui
demandes de t d non je me demande
surtout souvent d'aider les autres je
n'ai jamais eu envie de fonder une
famille
je ne rêve que de ça et je n'y suis pas
arrivé
oh
[Musique]
m
oh
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu